[Musica]
chi di voi nella vita ha avuto almeno
una volta la febbre alta
alzi la mano
si sarà quindi ritrovato in questa
condizione ha letto con i brividi dolori
articolari e magari anche con un forte
mal di gola
sono sicura che la maggior parte di noi
di voi in questa situazione si sarà
rivolta al proprio medico per capire
quale fosse il proprio stato di salute
in quel momento e come ripristinarlo nel
minor tempo possibile perché la prima
domanda che io faccio perché io in una
situazione del genere
devo rivolgermi al proprio medico e non
pensare di dover semplicemente ascoltare
il mio corpo e dargli la possibilità di
fermarsi mettersi sotto le coperte
prenderci un buon brodo di pollo e
aspettare aspettare che passi e uscire
quindi più forti di prima
da una sfida che il nostro corpo appunto
ha avuto passa continuamente il
messaggio che dobbiamo essere sempre
perfetti sempre al top che non ci
possiamo ammalare ultimamente c'è una
pubblicità che passa continuamente dove
c'è una ragazza che corre si ferma
perché ha un forte mal di gola e c'è
qualcuno che li dice no non ti devi
fermare c'è una pasticca
c'è una pasticca per tutto e anzi invece
di darti la confezione da 20 ti faccio
la confezione da 40 perché così almeno
ce l'hai sempre con te e sa che cosa
prendere sono anche sicura che in questa
situazione la maggior parte di noi di
voi ha preso un farmaco un farmaco che
gli è stato consigliato dalla nonna
dalla mamma la famosa tachipirina
semplicemente per abbassare la febbre
perché bisogna appunto subito ripartire
e senza fare alcun test spesso purtroppo
gli sono stati somministrati magari
anche
degli antibiotici sempre perché magari
che c'è un pochino di mal di gola cavolo
ma detto il fruttivendolo ma detto la
zia che basta che prendono argomentino e
tutto va bene quindi la seconda domanda
che io faccio è perché devo prendere un
farmaco senza nemmeno sapere se è quello
giusto da prendere
e a questo uso inappropriato dei farmaci
che ci ha portato in una condizione
drammatica oggi perché tantissimi e
batteri responsabili appunto di queste
malattie che per carità non sono gravi
spesso si possono risolvere sono
diventati resistenti agli antibiotici
siamo tornati come nel medioevo nel
medioevo si moriva per le malattie
infettive perché gli antibiotici non ce
li avevamo non li conoscevamo
oggi ce li abbiamo tanti fortunatamente
ma il loro utilizzo indiscriminato ha
portato a far sì che questi batteri
abbiano cominciato a difendersi e quindi
che siano diventati resistenti e quindi
noi non abbiamo più armi contro molti di
loro non so se avete sentito parlare del
new delhi il new delhi è un batterio che
si è sviluppato non tanto lontano da noi
nelle province di massa carrara che è
diventato resistente a tutti gli
antibiotici disponibili è una clip sella
pneumoniae una specie di batterio che
generalmente da una semplice cistite può
dare comunque delle banale infezione ma
se resistente se è divenuto resistente a
tutti gli antibiotici non abbiamo armi
contro di lui e ci può uccidere
quindi è probabilmente arrivato il
momento di fermarci e di capire che i
nostri comportamenti hanno poi delle
conseguenze delle conseguenze anche
molto gravi
la terza domanda che io vi pongo è
quella di fare un esperimento di
guardare la persona che accanto a voi ai
vostri stessi occhi i vostri stessi
capelli no è diversa da voi
questo perché noi siamo appunto unici
siamo tutti diversi perché allora io
devo prendere lo stesso dosaggio magari
della tachipirina che magari in quel
momento mi servo dell'antibiotico uguale
al mio vicino quello che è stato fatto
fino ad oggi è quello in questo gruppo
di persone che potete vedere qua di
fronte alla stessa malattia dare a tutti
lo stesso tipo di trattamento e soltanto
il piccolo gruppo in verde non ha avuto
effetti collaterali e il farmaco ha
funzionato
cioè era il farmaco o adatto in quel
momento è adatto a loro quindi quello
che dovrebbe essere fatto invece non è
quello di trattare tutti nello stesso
modo ma di capire qual è il farmaco
adatto a me il dosaggio adatto a me una
volta non era possibile fare questo non
lo sapevamo avevamo trovato la malattia
il principio attivo ok trattamento
standardizzato oggi questo è possibile
è possibile perché noi abbiamo un
libretto delle istruzioni che è il
nostro dna
il dna è una molecola che è formata da
una doppia elica arrotolata formata da
una sequenza di quattro basi azotate che
si chiamano nucleotidi adenina timina
citosina guanina e si trova all'interno
del nucleo delle nostre cellule fate
conto che sia srotolato alla lunghezza
di due metri e lì dentro c'è scritto
tutto su di noi ed è unico per ognuno di
noi è la nostra impronta digitale
dobbiamo semplicemente a darla a leggere
madonna sarà sicuramente un esame
costosissimo un prelievo dolorosissimo è
difficilissimo che io assolutamente non
posso fare per andare a prelevare il dna
vostro basta semplicemente un tampone
boccale è un
il tampone molto simile a un cotton fioc
che viene passato all'interno della
mucosa boccale si prelevano le cellule
di sfaldamento si trattano con
determinati reattivi e si può estrarre a
questo punto il dna la tecnica migliore
che abbiamo oggi a disposizione per
l'analisi del dna e quindi per riuscire
ad andare a leggere appunto tutta quella
sequenza e next generation sequencing il
sequenziamento di nuova generazione
una volta a questo tipo di tecnica
all'inizio ai suoi esordi comunque era
disponibile soltanto in centri in pochi
centri specializzati che non erano
accessibili a tutti
oggi invece è possibile fare questa
analisi
occorre sicuramente ancora dei centri
specializzati e del personale che sia
addestrato ma è fruibile da tutti noi è
un esame a portabilissimo fate conto che
quando è nato per fare il sequenziamento
di un intero genoma occorrevano giorni e
si dovevano spendere migliaia di euro
oggi è possibile fare questo esame in
circa 3 4 ore al costo di 100 euro
quindi con 100 euro voi potete andare a
leggere quelle quei capitoli del vostro
libro di istruzioni che sono coinvolti
nel metabolismo dei farmaci perché
quando noi troviamo un nuovo farmaco
troviamo il principio attivo e di
conseguenza sappiamo anche quali
all'enzima che lo metabolizza ad esempio
alcuni di noi hanno una mutazione alcuni
in alcuni enzimi che non ci permettono
proprio di metabolizzare quel farmaco
che quindi non è adatto a noi perché
semplicemente inefficace
in altri casi invece ci può creare degli
effetti collaterali
in altri casi ancora ne serve
semplicemente un dosaggio maggiore o
minore quindi non soltanto il principio
ma magari è il dosaggio che deve essere
aggiustato
ma se noi non andiamo a leggere il
libretto delle istruzioni non lo sapremo
mai
quindi
per minimizzare gli effetti collaterali
dei farmaci e quindi far sì che siano
nostri amici quando questi appunto siano
necessari dobbiamo andare a leggere il
nostro dna quello al quale io sto
lavorando però è quello di riunire tutte
le informazioni che sono scritte nel
nostro libretto di istruzioni in un
semplice codice a barre un codice a
barre che deve e può essere
continuamente aggiornabile dove c'è
praticamente scritto tutto tutto quello
che ci serve per mantenere e migliorare
il nostro stato di salute
tra ad esempio il nostro la nostra
capacità di metabolizzare alcuni farmaci
vi faccio un esempio
qualche tempo fa è venuta da me una
signora a fare un prelievo che era in
gravidanza e mi dice dottoressa senta ma
a me il ginecologo per telefono mi ha
detto guarda ai la febbre prenditi il
paracetamolo e la famosa tachipirina la
tachipirina infatti è uno dei farmaci di
elezione contro la febbre alta e che uno
dei pochi che ha consentito in
gravidanza per la maggior parte delle
per te le donne in gravidanza ma
probabilmente non per tutte perché
questa signora mi ha detto mi ha detto
di prendere il paracetamolo tachipirina
ok però io non mi ricordo la mia mamma
non si ricorda se quando ero piccola ho
preso questo farmaco io ho avuto degli
effetti collaterali come posso fare per
saperlo next generation sequencing
quindi andare a leggere quel gene che ha
coinvolto nel metabolismo del
paracetamolo e capire se è adatto a lei
se lei avesse fatto l'analisi del dna e
quindi la cosiddetta farmacogenomica lo
saprebbe e addirittura se lo
ricorderebbe o non avrebbe avuto bisogno
di ricordarcelo se questa informazione
fosse stata inserita nel codice a barre
quindi qualsiasi medico avrebbe avuto la
possibilità di andare lì con una
semplice pistole andra rossi e andare a
scaricare tutti i farmaci che era
possibile utilizzare per quella persona
tra quelli che avrebbe dovuto
prescrivere ad esempio in quel momento
tutto punto in un codice a barre ma io
direi ancora di più non soltanto per
quanto riguarda la farmacogenomica ma
tutti gli aspetti che ci riguardano sono
iscritti nel nostro libretto di
istruzioni perché se io vi dicessi ad
esempio che se sento levante al lattosio
potremmo essere depressi
che cosa c'entra intolleranza al
lattosio ah beh sono depressa perché non
posso mangiare niente guardo tutti che
mi guarda mangiano davanti e quindi sono
depresse ok no c'è una correlazione
perché sempre nel mio libretto delle
istruzioni
nel capitolo che riguarda la digestione
del lattosio e quindi in particolar modo
nel gene che codifica per l'enzima che
serve per digerire il lattosio che si
chiama lattasi io basta che lo elegge
poco a vedere se funziona tramite il
next generation si pensi per esempio
possono essere utilizzate anche tecniche
un po meno sensibili che sono ancora
meno costose rispetto al gene generation
sequencing che vi dicono guarda ok tu
hai una mutazione in quel gene non puoi
riferire il lattosio e questo cosa
c'entra con la depressione perché se io
non digerisco il lattosio il lattosio
arriva nel mio intestino in digerito nel
mio intestino
ci sono una serie di batteri che sono
possono essere i nostri amici i nostri
nemici o meglio se noi diamo loro da
mangiare le cose giuste
chiediamo un ambiente ottimale in cui
vivere
loro ci aiutano nel mantenere il nostro
stato di salute
se noi le nutriamo in modo scorretto in
questo caso dandogli ad esempio del
lattosio in digerito viene utilizzato da
batteri che sono nostri nemici e che
fanno e producono una serie di molecole
che hanno un effetto negativo tra cui
inibiscono per esempio la produzione di
serotonina
la serotonina l'ormone del buonumore e
e anche quel l'ormone che ha sul quale
agiscono tutti i farmaci antidepressivi
intolleranza al lattosio quindi
depressione possono essere correlati
non pensate che magari uno psicologo
avrebbe tratto vantaggio nel sapere se
siete intolleranti al lattosio e se
riuscisse ad avere una visione più
olistica della vostra unicità e sapete
anche un'altra cosa quale recipiente che
si trova in tutti in quasi tutti i
farmaci è il lattosio quindi magari ok
quel principio attivo io riesco a
metabolizzarlo quel dosaggio è giusto ma
cavolo io sono intolleranti al lattosio
quindi a me comunque quel tipo di
farmaco
mi fa male occorre che mi trovi uno dove
come incipiente non c'è lattosio quindi
all'interno di quel codice a barre ci
dovrebbero essere scritte tutta una
serie di informazioni che possono
chiaramente con il vostro consenso
essere utilizzate per mantenere il
vostro stato di salute perché spesso
facciamo le analisi si è vero ma ogni
ogni volta ce ne dimentichiamo dobbiamo
portarci dietro il cartaceo andiamo una
volta dal gastroenterologo una volta
dello psicologo una volta dal neurologo
e magari anche il medico in quel momento
non ha la capacità di individuare un
esame che real cui esito in realtà
potrebbe avere un risvolto sulla terapia
che può darvi ripetono di
farmacogenetica e magari detto leanza
all'apposita è stata prescritta dal
gastroenterologo però utile anche per lo
psicologo è utile anche per il
dermatologo perché ad esempio
l'intolleranza al lattosio può essere
associata la dermatite
venite curative non certo per una certa
causa quando in realtà semplicemente
basta togliere la dose
dall'alimentazione
quindi secondo quello che la scienza ci
dice se vogliamo migliorare il nostro
stato di salute mantenerlo
dobbiamo per forza andare a leggere il
nostro libretto delle istruzioni oggi
che è possibile dobbiamo avere accesso e
poter utilizzare queste tecniche
senza se e senza ma
grazie
[Applauso]